m night shyamalan's new film old  has proven that he can still make films  as bad as the happening  it feels like this film set cinema back  10 years  i watched this film thinking i was gonna  watch a psychological horror and it  turned out to be  a rip-roaring comedy i feel like i was  watching a scary movie film  it was that bad it's really  disappointing because m knight is a  super talented writer and director here  but you just wonder was he watching the  same thing we were watching  this just has all the horror tropes in  it and  it's just characters you cannot attach  to with  scenes that are supposed to be intense  but come off super super silly  it's a classic idea of a concept that  looks good on paper but then when you  make it  it comes out on film awful this can  happen but  something has to be fixed this is not  acceptable to even release audiences  it's a  total total steal of your wallets so i'm  giving this one a 2.9